you know I'm talking really can't you
gotta really look closely at my tats
awful God had that
what's up GQ boy Lance Stephenson I'm
gonna show you saw my tattoos my first
title wasn't on my chest and it was my
uncle rest in peace he passed away his
home that was my first tattoo
he's like a script you know scripture
yeah our is 16 okay I got it done some
hood guy so it was in the house yeah he
came to my favorite tattoo is fighting
our style Statue of Liberty to black but
you know it's the Statue of Liberty
right there represent New York from I'll
go up in Brooklyn Coney Island it's
getting much better as a as the years go
by but when I was there I was it was
pretty bad thought all those stars got
New York right here this is the bridge
yeah it's the Brooklyn Bridge I used to
run the book numbers a lot growing up
it means a lot yeah definitely I got
truly blessed then I got my family my
son my brother my mom my dad name and my
doors
um one the will and one the will is for
Coney Island the amusement park who dug
right here little design my daughter
drew up putting of idea or the joy she
did and I just took any put along my
hand kid's name
do you have any leg touches Oh got one
please Sir Lancelot you big camel on
time that's my grandfather name suppose
you have a least favorite tattoo yeah
actually it's under this like my second
title that have already and that was a
baby
like you said born ready and then a baby
in the middle and I like how to the
person did the baby so that's how I got
the one the will and stuff over it it
was a cartoon baby it was like a baby
with a ball ball in his mouth and they
had a basketball but I ain't like
high-low no I got him all when I was
young well from 16 to 18 I got all these
done that only knew the newest ones I
got is this to say all net right here
what's your general opinion on tattoos I
think it's cool but only four lights can
be you know dogs can't brothers they
really can't get no colors in any tats
when I see all my basketball player will
colors and they ties I like those who's
got the best hats in the league hinata
lead on well but I would say Birdman
Bernie ain't got it the coldest tags you
have any plans for future testers I'm
thinking about getting my bag done kind
of scared so I take my time with that
know I gotta figure it out we'll figure
out